the senate may not be able to meet its
self-imposed deadline to finalize its
details for a bipartisan gun reform deal
10 democrats and 10 republicans
announced a compromise package last week
to curb gun violence in the wake of
recent mass shootings but after several
meetings this week lawmakers are still
at odds mainly over two provisions
including what's known as the boyfriend
loophole that prevents domestic abusers
from owning guns christina raffini is at
the white house with more christina good
morning good morning dana well following
those shootings in uvalde and buffalo
lawmakers vowed to come together and
come up with common sense reform but the
longer it takes those senators to get
that deal to the floor for a vote the
longer its detractors have to pick the
legislation apart
as a teacher
i've imagined that scene in my own
classroom again and again
speaking to the national pta convention
friday first lady jill biden implored
congress to take action on gun control
we need to fight now for the lives of
our children and for the safety of our
schools this week a bipartisan group of
senators announced they'd agreed to a
basic framework of a deal including
enhanced background checks for gun
buyers under 21 and new funding for
school mental health and security
programs i'm more hopeful than ever
that we have a handle on all of the
issues
but lead republican negotiator john
cornyn had to defend the deal to a
hostile gop convention back home in
texas
but i will not
under any circumstance support new
restrictions for law abiding gun owners
that will always be my red line and some
republicans like fellow texan ted cruz
are already expressing concern about the
inclusion of so-called red flag laws
anyone that tries to take away our
second amendment rights i will stand and
fight to defend our liberties lead
democratic negotiator connecticut's
chris murphy says the group of senators
has committed to move forward with the
deal i have continued confidence that we
can
write that framework
into
into text and we can have that before
our colleagues next week
president biden has endorsed the
framework of this deal so has sent a
minority leader mitch mcconnell but
lawmakers still have to work out rules
about what they want to do there's a
provision that would ban domestic
abusers from buying guns they're also at
odds about what to do about sending
money to states that have red flag laws
that allow courts to confiscate guns
from people they believe pose a risk
michelle
a lot of work ahead christina thank you